Hello and welcome. I'm James Murphy.
In this episode,we're talking about the core guideline that says that you shouldn't use std::endl
and somecommon pushback about this guideline that I hear concerning multi-threaded code.
The core guidelinesays that most of the time you should just prefer to use a newline literal inside of your strings
instead of using the standard endline.
The reason for doing this is twofold.
Sometimes it avoids anextra write operation.
Here we needed a second call to the write operator in order to write the newline.
But here, we were able to just include it in our string since we were already using a stringliteral.
But even in a case like this, where you can't save the extra write operation,
it's stillpreferred to use a new line over standard endline.
The reason for this is buried in the standard. So,don't feel bad if you didn't know where to look.
But the effect of writing a standard endline
is to first write the new line character and then call flush on the stream.
Not all the time,but sometimes, flushing can be very expensive,
like if you're writing to a file, especially.
And in that case, doing unnecessary flushes will severely impact your performance.
If you'renot already familiar, a lot of output streams are buffered.
What that means is, when you write textinto this file object,
it doesn't necessarily mean that that immediately writes the text tothe underlying resource, in this case, the file.
Instead, it may just keep track of all the stuffthat you've written in an in-memory buffer
and then sometime later write all the stuff tothe file all at once.
The process of writing the in-memory buffer data of the file object intothe actual file on disk is the process of flushing
If we were to use endline because of the flushthat end line implies,
This means that we're going to be flushing and synchronizing with thefile system three times in this code.
Whereas, in this code, we don't necessarily have to flush itall until the file object is destroyed.
So, in its destructor, it would call flush and flush all thedata all at once.
The actual amount of speed-up you get from doing this is going to dependa lot on the relative cost of doing a flush.
So, for something like writing to a file, you'lltypically see a bigger speed up.
But for something like writing to standard out, you wouldn't see asmuch of a speed up.
It's not required by C++, but a lot of implementations will flush the buffer
forstandard out every time it sees a new line anyway.
In that case, if you use endline,
you're basicallyjust doing a redundant flush of zero characters immediately afterwards.
Any decent implementationwon't actually flush if there are zero characters.
So, your penalty will just be the penalty of anextra if-check.
However, whenever I suggest this guideline, inevitably someone asks:
Hey, doesn'tendline protect you in a multi-threaded situation?
I'm not quite sure where this myth originates frombut it's sure widespread.
And the answer is: No, it does not protect you at all.
Let's take a look ata simple multi-threaded example to investigate.
Here, I have a worker that takes in a start, astop and a stream to output to.
It just loops from the start until the stop
and output someinfo about which thread and what number it's on.
Then down here, I just start up twothreads that call the worker function.
The first worker is going to printfrom ten thousand to twenty thousand
and the second worker is going to printfrom twenty thousand to thirty thousand.
For this example, the stream I'm using is justa file stream going to this out.txt
Okay, I went ahead and built it and let's run it.
It appeared torun fine with no errors but let's check the output.
When we look at the output, we seeall kinds of messed up lines here.
Some lines like this one printed out just fine.
Other lines have sort of part of one line and part of another line mixed together.
And other lines arejust fragments of what they should be.
So, clearly this is not the output I was expecting.
So,what output was I realistically hoping for?
Well, I'm doing these two different chunksof work in two separate threads.
So, I can't really expect them to be ordered in anyparticular way with respect to each other.
However, the bare minimum that I could hopefor is that, I at least get complete lines.
Let's take that as our goal.
Suppose wedon't care the order the lines come in, only that we get complete lines.
So, how do weaccomplish that?
Well, as per the common myth, let's see what happens if we try standard endline.
Does this protect us in some way?
Recompile
Rerun
But the output is exactly the same, garbage.
Ihope this helps dispell the rumor
that standard endline somehow is better than newline becauseit fixes data races.
It clearly does not do that.
The underlying issue here was not whether ornot the data has been flushed to the file yet.
The real issue is that we have two threads tryingto write to the same place at the same time.
If changing a newline to an endline fixes thisproblem for you, then you got lucky.
Most likely this did not fix your issue and it just made itless likely to occur.
So, you now have the same bug that will only manifest in a very rare case.
Maybe it only happens every 100th time you run the program.
And honestly, to me a bug like thatis much worse than a bug that fails everytime.
At least, if it fails every time, I know somethingis wrong and can try to fix it.
If endline doesn't actually fix this, then what's the real fix?
Let'stake a look at the solutions for C++ 20, C++ 17 and C++ 11.
If you have the luxury of using C++ 20, it'sreally simple.
Start by including the syncstream header.
Make a standard osyncstream that wraps theoutput stream that you actually want to write to.
Then everywhere that you were going to writeto the output stream, write to the osyncstream.
osyncstream guarantees that it'ssafe to write to an output stream
from multiple threads as long as all of thosethreads write to it through an osyncstream object.
Under the hood, it uses some kind of lock or mutexin order to accomplish this.
It will acquire the lock or mutex on construction and release it whenit's destructed.
And while we're at it, since we're using C++ 20, we might as well use jthreadinstead of thread.
jthread is the same as a thread except it automatically joins in its destructor
so you don't have to remember to call join.
And here's the output. In that case, as you cansee, we get only complete lines in the output.
Of course, these threads are computing. So, theorder of these lines is not deterministic.
If I were to run this again, I would get somethingcompletely different.
So, the order is still not guaranteed. But at least, we don't have any mangledlines.
Okay, what about C++ 17?
osyncstream and jthread were added in C++ 20, so we needto use something else.
osyncstream took care of the mutex for us.
Prior to C++ 20, we needto do it ourselves.
So, include mutex and make a global write_mutex.
You might be tempted to justlock and unlock the mutex yourself and that would probably work.
But that's not the best solution.
The issue with this is that if an exception is thrown even if you handle it somewhere else,
youmight not release the lock in time.
In C++ 17, use scoped_lock.
It locks the mutex on constructionand releases it on destruction.
If you're using C++ 11 on the other hand, then use standardlock_guard.
It does the same thing as scoped_lock.
scoped_lock is basically just an all-aroundbetter version of lock_guard.
Of course, we can't remove lock_guard from the language becausepeople depend on it.
But notice that for lock guard, I have to specify this is a standardmutex, whereas for a scoped_block it was inferred.
And scoped_lock can handle multiple locks,whereas lock guard can only handle one.
So, that's the real way that you fix thesemangled lines in C++ 11 through 20.
Finally, let's take a step back and thinkabout the design that we have going on here.
I didn't really mention it before.
but anytimethat you really have two threads competing for the same resource like this,
you might wantto rethink your design.
Although the mutex is protecting us from undefined behavior and mangledlines,
it's not protecting us from bad performance.
We still have two threads that are constantlyfighting over acquiring this mutex.
This is going to be horrible for performance.
Instead, we maywant to implement our own buffering where we say,
write a thousand lines into a local stringstream
and then only try to grab the lock and write to the file every thousand lines.
This isgoing to be much better for performance
because each thread acquires the mutex a thousand timesless than it did before,
meaning there's way less contention.
And another design decision that youmight want to think about is that
it may not be the best practice to have each thread just tryingto write to whatever file stream or standard out or whatever.
In larger applications, it would be acommon design to have a single thread
in charge of all of the printing or writing to file that needsto be done.
And other threads just submit data to the printing thread through some kind of threadsafe queue.
Hey, thanks for watching and since you made it all the way to the end you get to hearabout the giveaway that I'm doing.
This is a paid editor for C and C++ that I'm using calledCLion.
If you'd like a chance to get a license for free,
then be sure to make a comment including#clion below.
Thanks to jetBrains for providing the licenses.
And as always, thankyou to my patrons and donors for supporting me.
If you enjoy my content, then please considerbecoming a patron.
Thanks and see you next time.